نحن على مقربه من هذا البوابه ان صح
التعبير
وهي للحدود المشتركه بين بيلاروسيا
وبولندا الحركه خلفي ستشاهد
سفيان بانها معدومه تماما كان الامر يتعلق
باضراب اقتربت قبل قليل من المسؤوله عن
هذا المركز شاهدت ان كان فيه صمت القبور
صح التعبير لا حركه باستثناء بعض حرس
الحدود قبل عامين كان هذا المكان في
الحقيقه يعج بحركه النقل شاحنات بضائع
باصات ايضا حركه بشريه لكن اليوم لا شيء
من كل ذلك طبعا اذكر انه على الجهه اليسرى
من هذا المكان هناك السياج الكبير الطويل
العريض اذكر بان طوله لا يقل عن 200
كيلومتر تقريبا حتى اكون دقيقه دقيقه
91 كيلو متر كلها
اسلاك شائكه لمنع كما تقول السلطات
المهاجرين من الدخول الى بولندا ولكن في
التطور الاخير كما تعلم سفيان هناك مخاوف
على حد ما تقول السلطات البولنديه المخاوف
من المجموعات التابعه لباجنير اليوم كنت
تحدثت الى اثنين من حرس الحدود فقلل من
اهميه الحديث عن وجود عناصر لكن سياسيا
هناك من يقول بان بولندا اصبحت تواجه خطر
اسمه فاجنر وخطر اسمه بيلاروسيا وحتى احد
المسؤولين قال بالحرف الواحد ان بيلاروسيا
منذ الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا اصبحت
الخطر الحقيقي على بولندا اضيف فقط بان
الاجواء الحاليه متوتره بين الجارتين
بروسيا وبولندا والدليل على ذلك ارسال
سلطات وارسو ما لا يقل عن عشره الاف من
الحرس الحدود ومن ايضا الجنود الى هذا
المكان الى الحدود الاربعه مئه كيلومتر
التي تفصل بين الدولتين اخر تصريح ربما
لافت يؤكد ويترجم حده التوتر بين البلدين
هو قول وزير الدفاع باننا ارسلنا ما يكفي
من القوات لكي نرضع اي محاوله استفزازيه
او محاوله للاضرار بوحده وترابي وسلامه
المواطنين البولنديين بقيه الاشاره سفيان
وباختصار شديد بان اليوم الانطباع السائد
بان ما جرى او يجري حاليا بين البلدين
اقرب كثيرا او جعل جلب الى حد ما يسمى
بالهاجس الامني لدى السلطات البولنديه
والدليل على ذلك انها ابلغت اكثر من مره
السلطات او الحلف الاطلسي